m.  président
cinq minutes monsieur le soir madame Joyeux
Noël Mike Mustang c'est une grande table
qui fait ressortir le paquet complet cela
viendrait-il de
tout le monde sait que vous avez fait la bonne chose
sur ce pont même le président sait que
vous devez apprendre à revenir dans
le réel  monde
monsieur  président nous sommes prêts pour vous nos
invités sont arrivés
je voudrais souhaiter la bienvenue à la maison blanche
monsieur
il y a eu une incursion soyons bas
donnez moi le Pentagone sur la ligne maintenant
Olympe est solide j'aime cette fleur
mr.  orateur, vous êtes le président par intérim,
je veux parler aux Russes pour qu'ils tournent à
l'est des Britanniques et des Français et que
tous si vous essayez de reprendre ce
bâtiment maintenant, laissez-vous votre
commandant en chef,
nous avons un contact de l'intérieur de la Maison
Blanche, identifiez-vous 3  : 09 er Jesus
Manny le même gars qui a été retiré du
détail du président,
il est un ex des forces spéciales 40 commandos
franchissent la porte il reste 20 ans pouvons-nous
lui faire confiance avec tout le respect que
je vous dois, je suis le meilleur espoir que vous ayez
pour la sécurité de  le président des
États-Unis,
nous parlons d'un enfer bien plus
que cela monsieur
ouvrez simplement les portes de l'enfer les États-
Unis d'Amérique ne négocient pas avec des
terroristes
qui ont dit quoi que ce soit à propos de vous négocier